and for original song score and it's  adaptation or best adaptation score the  nominees are the Little Night Music  adapted by Jonathan Tunick Pete's dragon  song score by Al kasha and Joe Hirshhorn  adapted by Irwin kostol the slipper and  the rose the story of Cinderella song  score by Richard M Sherman and Robert B  Sherman adapted by Angela Morley and the  winner is and the winner is Jonathan  Tunick for a little night  Stephen Sondheim has always been very  generous to me I'd like to thank him for  that  as well as for being the finest composer  in our theater I'd also like to thank al  Prince Elliot Kastner Hines logic for  giving a kid a break  and most of all my colleagues Paul  Gemignani John Richards an especially  Bob Hathaway music editor for his  enormous creative contribution to this  picture thank you  you